this is a production of Cornell
University
just to kind of frame this I think that
we started with the recognition that we
had some shared needs and we definitely
had some needs for new resources here at
the county level that realized that
maybe some of those resources would
serve on a statewide level so as we
developed our pollinator garden I
reached out to Sarah and said hey we
have some grant funding can we
collaborate on on curated or you know
interpretive signage for these
pollinator gardens because I don't know
if you all are kind of like us and that
a lot of what we do is what we can print
on our printers and what we can laminate
on our laminators and that's as big as
as it gets and as designed as it get so
so those kind of those kind of signs are
not I think they're great but they're
not they don't say hey this is a this is
a garden this is a learning space come
on in and they flap in the wind and they
float away so recognizing that we had
some parallel needs and we could develop
these shared resources I pulled a whole
bunch of people across the state and
said hey who's doing a pollinator garden
this year in terms of your extension
duties and a number were and would you
like signage so based on that we
launched into this collaborative process
which like many other things sort of
took longer than we expected because
life happens and then fairs happen and
then people go you know we're on
vacations and it took a couple of months
but we came up with some really
beautiful things and in doing that also
ended up developing a shared photo
library for other Extension educators to
use as well so out of it came this
wonderful set of products that I'm
really excited to be able to share with
people but as along with that are the
parallel photos that people could be
using and the parallel educators
resources that go along with it so
hopefully it's something that you can
just pick up for your program and take
what parts you need and it makes your
life easier
so how this was at a good
reduction Sarah yes what fun okay so we
are storing a lot of stuff in box so so
Sarah if you want you could I'll I'll be
your clicker and you talk and I'll click
on what you'd like me to show how's that
okay so essentially what you're about to
look at is that like Jen just mentioned
she pulled lots of people around the
county to say you know what kind of
concepts you want to communicate in in
your gardens and from that created draft
of text that then I took and and looked
at and said I made some suggestions as
to how to organize it and what we did is
we came up with four different signs
with four different concepts and in my
mind the do you mind clicking on the
pollinator paradise one first Jen sure
you know this is these four signs are
kind of like a menu of you could use all
of them you could use one or you can
select the ones that are most
appropriate for what you're displaying
in your garden but to me the pollinator
paradise is kind of the intro type of
sign that that kind of gives the why
behind you know it's at what it what is
the significance of making your home
landscape pollinator friendly and so
what you're what you're seeing right now
is the graphic layout for that
particular sign and it has like a fun
title that Jen came up with and then it
says you know explore this garden to
learn how you can create pollinator
habitat at home so that's our main idea
pretty much for all of the signs but
this one in particular kind of gives
gives the overview I mean in the
paragraph follow I won't read everything
word-for-word but the paragraph
following that you know sites the
significance for why it's important to
have pollinators they pollinate all the
plants we depend on for food and for
healthy ecosystems underneath that it
gives like a nice just basic here's what
pollinators need and all of all of the
signs direct people to more information
three of the four have QR codes so if
people have smartphones and like to use
their QR we reader
to access more information and website
they could do so the main idea behind
these signs is to really entice people
with beautiful images and not look
intimidating like there's too much text
all jumbled together but people can kind
of pick and choose the information they
want to read so the goal of this
particular sign not only to just you
know let people know hey it's a really
good idea to landscape your Agard your
home landscape with pollinator friendly
plants and also other aspects of it but
also like encourage them to say hey you
can do this and even you know go to the
0:c Society website and you can purchase
a neat little sign yourself that says
hey I'm doing this to make my pollinator
habitat friendly so those are the two
main concepts on this side and we were
lucky that Jen asked people around the
state to upload photos that they would
not mind us using so I had like 60 at
least images to choose from five so that
was like our main I just felt like let's
celebrate the photos so beautiful yeah I
don't know if we should oh go ahead
which agenda do you want to add
something well a lot of educators had
noted over the last couple years talking
to educators around the state that using
finding photographs that we have
permission to use has been hard and as
we put more stuff on the web and it's
more like publishing and then suddenly
we get into issues with do we have
permission to use a photo so building
this photo library was a nice kind of
corollary you know thing to this because
it's something that we've needed but how
do you ever devote the time to it well
the need and having some grant funding
towards that is one of the you know one
of the things that helps you do it
incrementally so yay we've got
pollinator photos you know next what do
we you know what do we need to collect
so that was really great to to grow our
photo library that way so and also it
was nice about that is that they every
single photographer probably thanks to
your direction put their name as the
file name yeah so that it was easy to
credit everybody without saying hey I
want to use this you know be on the
Rebecca image
who can you tell me who is it was so he
compared so all the photos are properly
credited to the photographer's too so
and and that photo library will also be
stored on the CCE shared resource
library that we're that we've been
piloting now for a while so people can
use them as well oh okay
or should I close this one and open a
different one sure unless anyone has any
questions about this one in particular
let me open the chat pod and this is Joe
Allen I'm just curious why when you're
listing the reasons that pollinators are
in decline that you didn't include
climate change
oh that's yes it was in there at some
point was it yes it was but I think what
the discussion was was habitat lost part
of the climate change discussion you
know what I mean that was that was that
was in there originally as a as a point
but then somebody made the point that
that the habitat loss well there's also
you know it's human that that was the
issue with the climate climate change
what would you agree on that yeah yeah I
mean I it were not alike no it can't be
emphasized by saying like habitat loss
partly you know in part due to climate
change it's not like we wanted not
emphasized you know we didn't purposely
try not to emphasize that climate change
is a factor I think it was more like we
just wanted to be like direct about like
you know what is what they're having
that loss and tell you yeah right and
also trying to be succinct I mean we
there was a lot of text and you don't
want to dumb it down you also want it to
be unassigned you have to be really
careful to make sure you don't you put
digestible amounts of text that people
are willing to read do people feel
strongly that it belongs in there no
they want to be changing a lot but it
came up a couple of times and that that
was kind of how we how how it how
comments winnowed it back down to this
because we did try to keep it brief what
do you think well the other thing is you
might notice that underneath a list of
what pollinators need there's a QR code
that that QR code leads to a website
that Jen created that gives because
there was like a whole like checklist of
specific things you can do in your
garden so Jen made this really great web
page I don't know if it's mentioned
there or if it could be expanded on
there right because we couldn't get it
all in the signs and we and then it
becomes an additional resource for
educators a that it's a colonial web
page that you could ask your web master
in your association to clone that web
page and then you would be able to add
stuff in there that you know means
something to your county versus having
to create the web page from scratch so
yeah we could you know it is it is in
there but it could be brought up more
and if you think it is if no people
think that this is something to change
the other beautiful thing about this is
that this is PDF and everybody has PDF
editors you can edit the QR code and if
there's something really important in
your garden that you're trying to
highlight there might be something that
you could you know there are places that
you can put things that make it unique
to your garden so we could look at that
too but so JoEllen I don't know if that
answers your question
it does but I can definitely see that
it's a space issue
I don't consider habitat loss to be
directly tied to climate change which is
one of the reasons that I thought it
should be in there but especially if
you're referring to it in other places
that they could find as it is let's see
if we really do the hook I mean the
process so you start with a lot of words
and then you come down to fewer and
fewer words and then you know you do in
order to make it short enough that
people will read it you definitely lose
some ideas yeah I mean I wonder if it
could just be like right on that last
line in the introductory paragraph it
says you know many of these pollinators
are in decline especially bees and
butterflies due to habitat loss and
upper pesticide use comma disease and
climate change it might all fit nicely
I'm fine yeah yep I bet it was if it was
bit I would said really like to see it
in there yeah okay I mean I'm coming
from a person who's you know like really
trying to elevate our climate change
interpretation here that I I don't to
make sure yeah like it won't do no yeah
change we can make we're not going to
really expand on that in the sign
anywhere but I think it's just this just
gives you the why behind it so I think
that's very appropriate yeah okay and
and I if I I'm sharing my screen I don't
think I can actually add a comment but
if you look on any of these box things
you can add comments as you use them say
hey great I downloaded it or this or
that but we can't you can't enter
comments
oh wait I can I can add in climate
change in there and that will be a note
for us too oh well if I learn how to
spell we know we don't you talk about me
okay
so then I'll close this one is that okay
and then do you want to look at another
one in particular no whatever you feel
is the the order that makes sense in
your mind
there isn't any particular order of
these signs I just wanted to highlight
that the pollinator paradise was kind of
if you know you know you had a small
garden where you only had room for one
to me I felt like we just wanted to have
a sign that kind of you know was like
just if you were only to choose one to
me that would be the one that would make
the most sense that's all yeah and then
this I think the pesticides one because
we just talked about potentially adding
information to and this one has a spot
for adding and whoops I see if I can get
that little thing on the bottom to go
away but it's it may not go away while
you're looking at it this was a sign
right Sara that that you had some room
for additions
I think it was all seasons one where
people could put their own QR code to
create their own plant list is that what
you're talking about
oh no on this one you can write in on
the right oh yes yeah yeah Jen wanted a
place where people could could write a
comment or people could leave comments
but you know there might be a new a tip
on you know not having to use pests like
in the latest IPM practices that you
might want to say hey check out this
article or you could even laminate an
article and post it like the
double-sided tape or something but I was
thinking like gel markers like if these
are created if they're laminated that's
very easy because you can just use gel
markers right on top of that black space
but if you get them fabricated say at
FedEx Office or staples and it's just
there's usually a finish they put on it
and the gel markers that have been
working really well with writing it on
there and when it you know when it dries
it the rain doesn't really affect it but
it does take like a simple green or just
like a cleaning solvent just to get it
off there great and that could be a
space where you know I think that this
is a hot topic often and there might be
something in the news or there might be
a change in pesticide labeling or
whatever it happens to be or even an
upcoming program that you want to
highlight is the spot where people could
keep the space alive you know it's a
place to way to change things or if you
don't want to change it you could pop
something in there again they're pdfs
and all of us have acrobat an editor PDF
editor that allows you to go in there
and edit things so it's there it can be
changed a little to make it you know
work for you so we did write right up
you know places you could get them made
how you can mount them just the you know
the logistics of what the cost range is
we can go through that after is it okay
if we go through that yeah we're gonna
make sure we leave enough time for Holly
so maybe
maybe actually we'll go through that now
I'll show you the signs quickly just so
you see them and how glorious they are
I'm sorry Sarah I think you did an
awesome job on them so and then the
photographer we had yeah yeah so this is
the idea be re go ahead generally you
know you go yep I would say the main
idea behind this one is to further build
on
you know what pollinators need is to
really get into the fact that having
something in flower throughout the
growing season is very important and
this gets really into specific to
emphasize the fact that you know certain
insects really have specialised with
certain plants so the far the right hand
kind of shows how there's specific
relationships between like Frankie I
should know all these by heart
considering that I wrote type this out
but you can see the different
butterflies and then what they
specialize on but we also wanted to say
that it's you don't need just native
plants that have specialists that you
can also have lots of non natives if
they're in flower that really appeal to
generalists too so we want to emphasize
that on this sign and so this is the
sign in which there's a QR code that
says scan here to view a plant list on
our website and then it says www type
your website he org well I get behind
this one is that if you have a plant
list you'd like to post on your website
here's your opportunity to create that
page and then generate a QR code and
place it in over the QR card we have
here the QR code that's here currently
is the QR code for the website above
that talks about plants and different
regions that are good good to plant like
a whole variety of pollinator so if you
don't feel like or don't want to make
your own unique plant list you could
just take that text away completely
using the Adobe editor and then just
keep that a QR code that's there does
that make sense to people because that's
the one little tricky part that I felt
people might have questions on
if that that's in the manual - so for
people who aren't on this phone call
that would that's explained okay yeah we
should go sorry
I know I talk too much and everyone I
don't know oh and then is this the one
we didn't look at these are essential
yes that's yep there we go the focus of
this one is just on beast specifically
to explain how they're in great decline
and how there's difference between honey
just kind of dispelling the information
that a lot of people sometimes get
confused on you know what height what's
honeybees versus the fact that there's
still thousands of native bees in the
United States but honeybees have you
know great function here as well though
they're introduced so it gets more into
just why they're essential then you
talked about the honeybees versus native
bees and then also generally felt it
would be a good idea to you know a lot
of you guys have said that you know
really dispelling the fear that bees can
sting you and that you wouldn't want to
welcome these into your habitat but
letting people know that it's mostly
kala native colonists not colonnades er
Holly oh so social bees that are likely
protecting their colony and that would
provoke them to be more apt to sting
versus solitary bees so trying to say
hey regardless of the fact that they you
know have attended the sting they're
very important so that's what we wanted
to decay a whole sign just to bees um we
wrote a just a two pager that just says
everything we just discussed so while
we're here that there are there are
going to be a whole bunch of supporting
resources for educators also in a
resources for educators things so
handouts articles that you could just
use on your local newspaper somebody
shared with us an announcement for a
pollinator program you know and how they
how they did
so we shared that as well as a template
for someone to borrow from and just you
know try yourself to do a program like
that I'm not sure that I have it here
but the guide it's not in here yet but
the guy does go through what you would
what you would do in terms of how to
print it right Sarah print how to print
you what size to print it on who to get
from how to mount it what you need to
change so kind of guide to go along with
it hey Jen this is Laurie one of the
things you were asking about is if you
could get some feedback on how people
are using it yeah I wonder if in this
guide you put a link to a Qualtrics
survey although so then if an educator
uses the material they could fill out
how it's being used I mean it would be
optional but I think I think people will
be very thankful that you did all this
work it might provide you a little
feedback on how they're using it from I
don't I think I would ask why not right
right I think we had like assigning in a
visitor's log idea on there but maybe
that would be just more instant yeah so
that could be your visitors log and also
it could be like if you fill out this
form you'll be you'll be notified of
emerging you know changes in content you
know earth maybe other people have ideas
about what would motivate people to just
give you a little bit of information
about how they're using air or have used
it well I have to say the nice thing
about getting a lot of photographs from
people is that they want to see if their
photographs got used you another second
decision oh yeah no but that's written
brings another question how do we get to
people to know that the resources are
there and that they can use them you
know that's the that's the other thing
is getting the word out and I don't know
what that maybe I put it out on the Hort
listserv and say hey come come get it
you know I don't know yeah and the other
question I have is do you have an
evaluation tool
oh gosh oh maybe it's coming you what
kind of to evaluate yeah I'm for people
who are visiting sign oh oh yeah in the
garden you mean yeah yes that was one of
our hopes to do yeah how do we have you
get people to evaluate Sarah maybe you
have a better idea when people come to a
garden how do you get feedback from them
yeah that's always ongoing struggle I'm
actually right now testing that well I
mean essentially the best way to do it
is you know if we you know you eat we
have you look back at what your learning
objectives are for each panel and then
you ask questions to evaluate whether
what you know ask questions the visitors
to indicate whether those learning
objectives were met or not I mean so one
thing you and I could do John is sit
down and say for each panel say okay you
know here are the learning objectives we
felt were important on this panel and
then create some generate some questions
that if you know an educator has time to
ask a handful of people you know hey
would you mind taking five minutes to
answer a few questions that that is um
kind of a standard way to evaluate right
or you can have them fill out a little
form you know I often feel like it's
often more effective the visitor my more
likely to tell you the right the
information you're looking for is if if
you just they spoke it because sometimes
people are like sure I'll write this to
fill out the survey and they never do
right right well that's that that would
be an educator would have to be there
right yeah or a person who's an
interview person like a person yeah
right I mean I know that like I worked
helped like a children's garden with
some interpretive panels and we had a
little QR code in the bottom and said
hey tell us you were here and tell us
what you liked about your visit and that
was one way that they're hoping they're
going to get feedback the panels aren't
up yet so we don't know if people have
actually done it or not I always just
say if you really want to get the
information you have to do
in the easiest way possible so it's like
dedicate and two hours for an educator
to go out there and ask ten people you
know it does very well right and it's
probably easier to do one a garden day
some of you are having garden days and
you've got folks out there and you're
doing programs hands-on to have to have
a volunteer assigned to just kind of
wandering and asking hey would you mind
answering a few questions
yeah awesome okay yeah great no I just
say Volunteers of the bet like that's
what I'm thinking that I'm going to do
for a project that I'm currently working
on here and have a volunteer hang out in
our welcome center for a few hours
each Saturday and ask people about the
exhibits that they're in interacting
with right because we do need that
feedback we put it out there and we hope
that people are going to come visit it
and then and then we see people wander
through or we know that they're down
there but we don't really know what they
think and Holly wrote some things in the
chat window about getting people to how
do we get it out she suggested maybe
you're doing a webinar and and or even
just recording a webinar and it could be
you know or even a recorded PowerPoint
that they could use at regular Master
Gardener business meetings to let
different associations know that it's
there and that the volunteers might be
interested in and taking it in that next
step and getting them printed out and
installing them in their gardens because
awesome they're really yeah the
PowerPoint might be good for like the
first garden who puts them out there to
kind of show take pictures a each step
meaning like you know here's the here's
the material we printed on here's how we
installed it can even be like a little
YouTube video yeah we're down there you
know that like shows the process yeah
which is another great project even that
for a volunteer to put together so yeah
yeah cuz um maybe I'm saying maybe that
sounds too wishy-washy but I'm thinking
because I want to use the pollinator
paradise sign and put it in our
pollinator garden and so we're lucky
that we have a crew a construction crew
so I can make a request for them to put
it in but if I can say hey can you tell
me when you're going to make the sign
base I can go videotape them doing it
and then just kind of splice together a
little fun instructional you know
narrative to go along with it right yeah
yeah that would be probably till the
spring but yeah yeah I don't know but
that's a good idea I think you know it's
Anna wish I could be on the wish list
for sure oh yeah yeah so we took we took
a half an hour I and I hope that that
gives people some idea of what what's
out there what we did this is how we're
expanding our education our display
gardens here in Oneida County and one of
the gardener's part of our perennial
garden a lot of people around our area
and probably throughout the state are
concerned about deer browsing in their
perennials so this is a sign that we
have in front of this garden that is
made up of deer resistant plants and you
can see she said visit Cornell
Cooperative Extension website factsheet
on the deer resistant plant and there's
the garden in our little plaque would at
st. pitchers right there in the center
of it and we also wrote a news article
for the local newspaper about it too to
bring more people out to see the gardens
this particular garden in the butterfly
house their goal was to provide visitors
a place where they can learn about life
cycle monarch butterflies the types of
milkweed plants needed by caterpillars
and nectar producing life needed to
sustain the life of a butterfly
objectives they post a large graphic
display of the life cycle of the monarch
butterfly plant two types of milkweed
common and swamp and explained with
signage the importance of preserving
milkweed and what type of monarchs use
plant and label a variety of nectar
producing plants provide a mud puddle
for butterflies to use and display
recipe for mixture
display fun facts about monarch
butterflies and you'll see that my
circle next slides create a brochure
that explains how to grow butterfly
garden at home in their assessment as
visitors exit the butterfly house ask
them to fill out a survey about their
experience and knowledge gained and
you'll see our survey box and I'll go
into that and we did have the spine
soldier bug attack our larvae of our
monarch caterpillars this year and that
kind of devastation to our monarch
display this year but here's the signs
they created that go throughout the
house
and then that's lifecycle display and
they're looking for a big laminated
poster from educational site that would
have the monarch lifecycle little better
these were pictures that we took on one
Milla gardeners made over the years ago
and there's some butterfly Mud Pie
the recipe right there and then take a
survey this is as they exit the
butterfly house and then we have the
information box there that we had
brochures in about making a butterfly
garden and like what plants the
butterflies like and then the surveys
are in the info box and they just leave
them right there with the pencils
and here's another sign right there
caterpillar systems for Chinese eyes to
Nancy and this was our we educated
public because many were coming to see
the butterflies and what happened to him
and we had those right on our door
posted an explanation of what happened
and when some kids came I was out there
talking to him and they seemed like the
explanation they learned more something
that there's predators to the
butterflies and that was what they
we also had some other culprits in there
too Munson
so nice too
and our pollination garden and I like
how you did the signage for pollination
paradise this is well tying nicely for
the area and our Gardens next year
all-american selections we participate
in that organization every year we sign
up to receive seeds which a local high
school
FFA group starts the seeds for us and
their annuals and also vegetable seeds
but this year their theme was pollinator
education and we participated in their
landscape design contest and this is how
we incorporate the pollinator education
into this annual brick garden here and
we had a submit that we have the plants
all labels and they do provide some
labels for their plants and we had a
gentleman who has a friend of one of the
gardeners who made up some recyclable
water sources that the pollinators could
use that were creative mold sponges in
there to soak up a nectar solution that
they made and one of the gardener's
grandsons
was a member of a Cub Scout or Boy Scout
group and he made a mason bee house and
that was all put in the garden and
labeled there for people to see and
there's another shot of the nectar and
what is pollination sign there and then
the overall we end up creating a mobile
and then we have beetles butterflies
hummingbirds and birds on there and it
tells a little more about the different
pollinators and it kind of moves around
with the wind
and all-american selections like how we
worked with the different community
groups we involve 4-h ER and AARC
schoolwork kids help in the gardens too
and we received honorable mention this
year for what they did with the
education and that's kind of how we this
year have added a little more education
to our garden
and thank you Sarah for getting us
rolling Oh Holly this is Jen that is
really cool that you worked movement
into there that's really awesome that
that moves people see things that move
and it tracks them you know but I saw
that a Fiona had a question earlier and
I think this is probably something we
all would benefit from knowing is when
you create interpretive signage how many
like how would you know what's enough
how many words should be on a sign or
are there any other pointers I don't
know if we saw that in the chat window I
don't know Sarah if you have any rules
of thumb that you could share
webex undo itself or a fun presentation
I mean the quick and dirty I mean
there's a lot I could say and I
certainly don't want to take up
everyone's time but they're definitely
like there's definitely interpretive
research about like how many chunks of
words should be together before people
start getting tired of reading it so I
never exceed 75 words I try and I try to
even do a lot less if possible in one
chunk of words and some people recommend
you know don't exceed 150 words per sign
now I try not to do that too much but I
also feel like the key thing about
interpretive signs that I feel is most
effective is giving a title that gives
you the understand idea of the whole
sign an introductory paragraph
underneath that that again summarizes
what the sign talks about and then the
chunks of text that are kind of
secondary to that reinforce that main
idea with clear headings that tell you
what you're going to talk about so that
way people there's a hierarchy people
could walk by a sign they could read the
title may be the introductory paragraph
and they're going to get the main idea
you want to put forth and everything
else reinforces and gives even more
detail to that main idea to me that's
the key way to structure an interpretive
sign and again try I assume people
aren't going to read everything but I
always assume that so I assume that like
there's like have you guys ever heard of
like the three-second three minute and
or 30-second three-minute rule the
people that most people are going to
look at a sign for three seconds so in
those three seconds you're going to get
them to read the title and maybe the
other headings the thirty second people
might read the heading the main title
the introductory paragraph and the main
headings to the other places and then
the three-minute people will if you you
know really stick to you know 150 to 200
words might read the whole thing but I
give people the opportunity to dig
deeper and the headings I feel are the
invitations to dig deeper like I
honestly when I go to a
Museum and I see like a whole long
paragraph I'm like those people didn't
want me to read it it's like they didn't
invite me to read it so I just I don't
I'm not a reader so I'm a good person a
great interpretive side because I don't
even like to read I mean I like to read
books but like if I'm enjoying a garden
I don't want to have to read a ton of
information right you're moving yeah
yeah yeah very helpful yeah and so I
mean I'd be happy to do like a like
actually prepare kind of a presentation
on what I've learned in the interpretive
realm over that you know the course of
my career with just like the kind of
tips and basics if you guys are
interested in that but but to me it's
like the key is inviting people to want
to read more if you don't make the
effort to try to rope them in by you
know headings that tell you what they're
going to read about no one wants to read
and then process what they just read
they want you to tell them write a
youtube video yeah it's like five
minutes or ten minutes yeah just like to
give a few examples and I feel like the
pollinator ones you know that you know
we graduate we haven't evaluated them
with people but we could I could use
that as a way to like you know what the
what drew me to design it in that way
yeah and then the other thing which I
think you did with Holly and her group
that was so critical is even before you
get to the signage mm-hmm you go through
that process of what are the messages or
the main goal of this space somebody
works through that process of
identifying their their main themes and
their what Holly was describing you you
took her group through is probably
critical to getting to that point of
where okay now I can decide what my
title is going to be because I know what
I want yeah exactly
yeah it's like I'm creating what the
main theme is for the like for instance
the pollinator paradise our main theme
was here's the way you can create a
pollinator paradise in your in your
garden and you know Jen was really good
about creating catchy fun titles now
Holly I just wanted to know what the
mobile was made out of his at metal
it's a PVC pipe Oh
nice that's awesome when was it made by
the group that it was at the 4-h group
well I had one for ager and two Master
Gardener volunteers kind of helped to
guide her on it and so and then we've
laminated and used rings we had like
pull ties before but now we have like
the three binder ring type things
hooking to the sign and we had to use
them duct tape to kind of reinforce it
because this fall the winds have gotten
stronger up here and that was kind of
tearing it before year one but I mean it
was fun to make and it's nice and light
and we can use it for other things to
cool and congratulations Holly that's
really an awesome thing to get
recognized you know and sometimes we
don't do a great job of Tooting our own
horn but you know that's really awesome
the gardener's yep they they do a lot
hard work and I'm glad they participated
in the contest huh thank you
anything anything else is great very
informal actually I feel like we should
have like a workshop on a regular basis
for people to share what they're trying
and how they're trying it and as you
because as you said Jen it was better to
do it as a collective yeah and then to
try to do do this sort of thing on our
own because we all have our own you know
you just only see one way right and so
you get all these comments and you
always filter them through your lens you
know your lens of what you need and
where you are working and that kind of
thing but they open the door to like aha
you know maybe we should try that or you
get these great ideas like we might
steal from Holly now of having something
that moves in the garden like that you
know so yeah so so it'd be fun that
maybe maybe maybe this is where Cornell
plantations has a role we come
Cornell plantations for a summer
workshop would be fine a son thank you
are of different signs and yes and other
types of interpretation besides signs
like creative ways you know - I mean
signs are great there they can be
low-cost and you know they're always
there you can't have people there all
the time right
but there's we've been trying to add
mobile tools to give people guided tours
of our gardens and yeah yeah I like like
other people sharing like Holly did and
just like Jenna and I did you know like
hearing the other creative ideas people
have been doing - so people can like
build on each other I'm sorry I just
wanted to mention really quickly because
Jen had mentioned how difficult it can
be to find images and the New York State
IPM program has a Flickr site and we
have albums specific to pollinators and
also bees and a wasp but I was looking
at the bee poster I noticed that you had
a photo captioned about how the the wasp
will collect wood fibers to build their
nests and it reminded me of a photo but
I was luckily able to collect showing a
paper wasps actually scraping the wood
off so it's good to know that those
kinds of things are available and Joe
joylynn that was a great sharing and
actually somebody suggested that we
shared that we borrow some photos from
there which we did and and credited the
photographer's but did you do you all
have access access to that Flickr site
or anybody with a Flickr account can see
it right any I don't even think you have
to have an account to see it no you just
need to go to Flickr and our garden
based learning also has a Flickr site as
well it's not it well no it's not
available right now because we are I
think sarah has a few more changes to
tweak and now we're going to add climate
change if we can into that line um and
then that that will all go
on to the CCE resource educators
resource sharing site and at that point
if you would like I will just add you if
you're not already added but we used to
have slides actual slides with a script
so you would get rocks in the mail yeah
this is this is more of a sandbox
location and and so what we're trying to
trying to get a little more skill that
sharing stuff that we're developing so
people aren't developing the same thing
in separate world right although
sometimes since we're do we are what I'm
trying to say we're developing them
simultaneously that sometimes we end up
with this overlap naturally and it was
just because I put that query out to the
whole group on the listserv that I think
somebody from New York State IPM said
hey we have this whole file sharing site
on Flickr and I was like a wonderland
you know somebody opened up the door to
Oz in the back it was all these
wonderful photographs that I just didn't
know existed so it's just throwing it
out there and having that that casual
kind of conversation that we have online
that helps make those connections I
think great well thank you yes thank you
everyone at YouTube bye-bye
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu